there's a man called brandon michonne
trying to read more
from those books daring to read aloud
from the books
that louden county children are told to
read
watch how they try and shut him up as he
does
i'm going to read an excerpt from a
freshman honors
english class in stonebridge she's a hoe
just like her sister every dude on the
courts
it's time for lcps to get their axe in
their house in order
the curtain has been pulled back and
people can now see the deficient
leadership that's been in this county
my five-year-old is being peddled
transgender books in her library
teenagers are being served pornography
under the guise of young adult
literature
do something be a leader
because if you know what the citizens of
this county deserve better
and if you're not willing to do it can
you please cover your nose with your
mouth you're all vaccinated what the f
what the freak give me 10 seconds back
give me 10 seconds
back there you know the rules thank you
wear your mask when you criticize us
it's a pandemic
in the end they just cut off his mic on
this show we are happy to hear
what he has to say so that man brandon
meeswan joins us
right now brandon thanks so much for
coming on um
you are told to wear your obedience mask
when you speak to your elders and then
in the end they just they just shut off
the pa system wouldn't let you talk at
all so
so finish your sentence if you would on
this show we were not going to cut your
mic
what were you trying to tell the school
board in loudoun county
yeah well the message to the school
board is parents are fed up
and the curtain has been pulled back
across the u.s and the education system
and what we're seeing in
what you saw in the videos you posted
before
were are you know the the children are
being
shown material that hollywood can't even
make into a movie that they can watch
and so i'm just asking for them to step
up step up
and be leaders and if you're not willing
to do it
step aside or if you're not willing to
do it
find a way for others to you know find a
solution for you
what one thing i notice about all the
different revolutionary changes they're
inflicting on our kids is that they're
all dumb
and the standards have have been
completely debased so we can't teach
math because it's racist we can't teach
real books because they're racist
but the things that replace math and
literature are
dumb i mean they're not well written
they're not smart this is
we're making the kids dumb are they
aware of this
i i don't know i think every time we ask
for answers there's no response i think
you're seeing local officials looking to
state officials who are looking to the
national government who's looking
backwards to state and local
what we need is our school boards to
bring it back to education
we need our school boards to make and
put each other
accountable we need them to say enough's
enough right if you have an
administration who's put in material
that isn't appropriate
make change but if you're not willing to
do that then
you know listen to the parents because
they're the ones who are having to
deal with this on a daily basis this
is at least the second time that you
have told the school board what you
think
how have people in your community
reacted to those widely shared videos of
you telling the truth in a school board
meeting
it's been overall positive i mean i've
heard from people all across
the country saying thanks for speaking
up thanks for being you know
an advocate for the students but what
we're trying to do at least locally
is we're trying to get the school board
members out of there we have we this
last weekend we got 1500 signatures
to try to remove six of the board
members who are you know actively
not trying to participate and put the
education first
they care more about themselves and what
they post on facebook than they do about
the better education of young students
i just i i can't say that strong enough
bless you for not being passive and for
trying to fix it really quick do you
think you can get
these school board members bounced
soon i would hope so we built a lot of
momentum
but the thing is all across the u.s
parents are becoming vocal
and what teachers have unions but
students don't have a union what they
have is parents who care for them and
parents who want to see their best
education
and what we can continue to do is fight
for that the best education for our
families and for our children
that's right stay and fight brandon
meeshan thank you so much for what
you're doing for joining us tonight
thanks for having me hey sean hannity
here hey
click here to subscribe to fox news
youtube page
and catch our hottest interviews and
most compelling analysis
you will not get it anywhere else